one of our favorite guests as a matter
of fact let me make sure I get this
correctly the NFL Network went on the
air
and he was in the middle of his first
season with the Cincinnati Bengals as
the first overall selection sitting
there I guess watching waiting now he's
a retiree on behalf of FedEx Aaron
ground a man who had many many footballs
thrown at him by uh from at Larry
Fitzgerald and walk-throughs back in the
day I mean the number of times laughs
its Joe threw a ball at this man in a
walkthrough and stormed off and then
wound up on a reality show singing in a
blue hippopotamus outfit I've lost track
some glad carson palmer's here on the
show how are you Carson Rick I'm great
how are you yeah but that always happen
right you and Larry Fitzgerald got into
arguments walked countless times he was
such a prima donna don't you think I
mean such a showboater you know although
every time he scores a touchdown he gets
flagged he does some extravagant dance
he's such a showboat er yeah whatever
got into him you never used to be that
way
so you know did you ever have a radio
show Carson you ever do that radio show
thing on a Tuesday or I'm under or
Tuesday did you have one of those no I
stayed away from my off days were were
my off days so you never went on the
radio like Big Ben and had an
opportunity to review things that people
thought needed blame side and then
passively aggressively went ahead and
assigned it to your teammates you never
did that Carson I always felt like
because every city I played and those
opportunities came up but I always felt
like you're just opening the door for
there's not a lot of good that can come
out of it well only the drama gets
brought up and then Ben gets put in a
situation where he's got to answer
questions about that as opposed to the
game but they just beat the Bengals but
I just always I always stayed away from
that kind of stuff yeah I know well
ending in Micah was your so but you
never offered me an opportunity
you know Carson I always set traps for
you you know and they see you'd always
stay away I always set those traps for
you you know and you walked right into
them every time so then you start
bawling you know how is the house life
for you how's everything great great I'm
uh as you know we we moved to Idaho
bumped into you and and had a glass of
wine or
a steak dinner a time or two and I got
wait for the next one
mmm but I'm in New York City I got out
of the mountains I'm in New York City
I'm working with FedEx and yep promoting
the FedEx air and ground players of the
year and it's a terrific honor for
myself and it's exciting time of the
year the opening they open the voting
just today actually and Moses on the
31st of this month so make sure you log
on to NFL comback slash FedEx or to
Twitter NFL homepage and vote yeah the
air finally the nominees for the air
award of the year drew brees mahomes and
Phillip Rivers just moments before you
joined the program here at Carson the
all-pro team was announced and the first
team all-pro quarterback is Patrick
mahomes / Brees and everybody else I
mean would you I know you want to put
your thumb on me FedEx air award winner
scale here but this kid has been
remarkable Carson is he the best QB in
the league do you think it's tough he
had the best season in the league it's
tough to clown somebody after one one
season but I mean look at through 50
touchdown passes I don't think the
general public in the NFL fan base
understands just how many touchdown
passes 50 is in 50 test out of 30s a lot
of touchdown passes but 50 it was truly
amazing he's a ton of fun to watch and I
can't wait to you have to wait a whole
week to watch him play again but I can't
wait again now all that said so he it's
his first foray in the playoffs
same with deshaun Watson same with Lamar
Jackson same with Mitchell true Biscay
going into this weekend what is it that
makes it so difficult for the first
playoff appearance and I understand what
yours was but what what difference is it
playoff two regular season that makes it
so difficult for quarterbacks to perform
well in their first ever playoff game
well it's not that the game speeds up or
guys hit extra hard or guys are playing
you know at a different pace or playing
with a different intensity
it's just that you losing your dot
you're losing you go home you work so
hard to get that far and you know if you
lose you're done and then you've got to
watch other teams play I think that's
the biggest challenge and that's the
biggest challenge for these guys to not
think about I mean Patrick just needs to
go out and play and do what he did to
get here because what he did to get here
is good enough to win a playoff game or
to class me and your three playoff games
but once you try to put too much on it
and you just start listening to all the
hype around you you put a little too
much pressure on yourself so really
these young guys just need to go out and
play their game and do what they did to
get here so it's not like a different
crucible sort of like I guess in the NBA
where it's more of a half-court game and
rotations get tightened when the
playoffs hit there really is no
different style of play in the playoffs
it's just the the mental aspect of
knowing you're done if you if you screw
it up or you don't get the execution
down right yeah I mean these teams are
good teams and and these coaches know
that they they are on good staffs ropes
they wouldn't be here and they have good
players well today wouldn't be here so
these guys not gonna you know the Kansas
City Chiefs aren't putting in a bunch of
new plays the the LA Chargers aren't
going to change what they're doing or
that song they're gonna do what they do
best you know when we when you talk
about the San Diego Chargers they're
gonna run the ball with Korda now that
he's back and healthy you know and
they're gonna take their play action
shots they're not gonna you know Riaan
built reinvent the wheel so to speak and
change what they do it's an exciting
time of year and I think the most
exciting thing about these playoffs is
everybody's in it you know every you
could easily say any one of these teams
maybe not maybe not Baltimore but any
one of these teams you could see when in
the Super Bowl and and I feel like you
rarely have that kind of feel going into
postseason why not Baltimore Carson well
I just don't I love their defense I just
feel if they get behind and they have to
throw they're gonna be in trouble where
all these other teams they can run it
they can throw it they can play good
defense but Baltimore so built on that
defense in that running game that if
they catch a you know a 14-point deficit
in a position where they got dropped
back and throw it they're just not built
that way
now is that because you hardly ran the
ball yourself as a quarterback in the
league Carson or you do just now coming
back from retirement from the retirement
chair just being spiteful because of
lack of our bread I was an absolute
thorough
what was your 40 ton my 40 time was
great come on is it didn't my I ran like
I ran for 60 I could run straight line
fast its way as soon as I had to make a
move I might pop an Achilles tendon or
break my knee in half I I could go when
I had to go straight ahead but as soon
as I am and unfortunately there were
notes you know just straight past the
end zone he always had to run or Duke or
get out of somebody's way I just didn't
have that ability but okay you got a
stack guy there look at the 40 times
apparently what is it Chris Prague 465
hilarious Larry Fitzgerald 463 Carson
nothing would be sweeter than if he ran
for six second he did footballs at you
and walkthroughs I knew it
do you know off the top of your head
mister I don't think Lamar Jackson can
do it your number of rushing yards and
careers for your career would you happen
to know your career come on you're a
tremendous Louch 301 yards know you had
eight rushing touchdowns okay that's not
too bad you six five eight rushing to
[Laughter]
like you could do that yeah if you
played football for 15 years I think you
could find a way to score you touch well
did you see Brady finally amassed his
1,000th career rushing yardage you see
that car yeah but do you also see that
in the game in which he did it he took a
victory formation knee and made sure
that the referee did not spot the ball
behind the line of scrimmage so he did
not lose the record of 1,000 and so
before I let you go the ground award
finalists are girly Zeke and say qualm
Berkeley where do you stand on the
subject of of Berkeley / Eli and folks
in New York think that did the wrong
thing by drafting of running back
instead of a potential future in Sam
darn old fellow USC Trojan Carson would
you stand on the subject it's a great
question I mean I think say Kwan is is a
game changer and and he's absolutely
worth the first second third fourth pick
you know I just there's not going to be
another State Kwan in this draft and
maybe not another one next year and the
way that position is valued now is you
draft them high and then you let
somebody else pay them because once they
hit that kind of 27 28 29 age then they
start you know the production drops and
and their contracts start to go down and
everything's kind of set up right now
the way the league and in that positions
valued to draft one high and you give
them a ton of carries and you get
everything you can and then you let
somebody else pay them and and that's
kind of unfortunately that's kind of
what's happened to Olivia
Le'Veon does he's produced produced
produce produced and then when it's time
to get paid and signed a long-term deal
they're just not going to do it they're
gonna have somebody else do it but I
like to pick you know he'll I felt like
he had another year left the team felt
like he had another year left the
defense had a great year the previous
year so they thought they might have a
shot unfortunately it didn't work out
for them but you know they'll they'll
probably get one more year out of Eli
but they'll have say Kwan and until that
rookie year deal or that rookie contract
is up and then I'll move forward do you
have a couple quick headers for you in
the college football world Carson do you
have any two cents on what's happened to
the pac-12 and you obviously USC is
suddenly now on a down-and-out despite
having the ability to recruit the people
that clay Helton can recruit do you have
a theory on this at all I think it's
just cyclical unlike the SEC the pac-12
has some years where and USC is good
UCLA's good organs good and there's
always like an outlier like a Washington
state or in Arizona you know it's just
the cook law I think you know it won't
be forever it won't be for five years I
think we're
in the next five years you'll have a
team out of the the pac-12 going to the
playoffs and then another team going to
a big big bowl game so you know I don't
think all of a sudden everybody's
leaving the west coast and going to
school in the south I just think it's
cyclical you don't have the same amount
of players staying on the west coast
that the South has with with all those
players that stay in the south and and
there's more tradition and and and just
you know figure football bigger fan
bases in the south and the SEC and so
they consistently always have a team in
the playoffs that consistently always
have a top a top ten team or two or
three top ten teams or the pac-12 it's
just unfortunately it's just a cycle
every year every couple years there's
one or two really good pac-12 teams and
then every couple of years there's no
good pac-12 team so I think in the next
couple of years or you know get hot
again you said UCLA I'll get better with
Chip Kelly and hopefully I sneeze right
behind and last one for you who'd you
vote for in the Heisman I voted for
calimary I thought he was the best
player in the country you know I think
you know after watching him play against
too and in last week's game you know I
still felt that way I still felt like he
might have been the best player in the
country just to I had a lot more talent
on both sides of the ball around him but
he's one of the most fun players to
watch since since Johnny Manziel last
year at Texas A&M
all right Carson I've just been told by
our stat people that Eli Manning has 311
career rushing yards if you if you've
ever wanted to come out of retirement
maybe just one 10 11 yard run and and
then tap out go back to out on there
what was the utilize 40 times do we have
utilize 40 time over there crisp Rocklin
for nine to try get back pedal faster
than molasses that's what he is
hey send my best to the family Carson
let's chat soon
you do the same thanks rich you got it's
Carson Palmer the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience